Wirklich ein unglaublicher Tag für
KI-News, denn es gibt viele spannende
Dinge zu besprechen. Beginnen wir mit
Google: Sie haben intern ihren ersten
neuen Gemini Pro-Checkpoint
veröffentlicht, der möglicherweise
Teil der kommenden Gemini 4.0
Pro-Modellreihe sein könnte. Dies ist
der erste neue Pro-Checkpoint seit
geraumer Zeit, und die ersten Anzeichen
sehen bisher extrem vielversprechend
aus. Die Modell-ID ist öffentlich
sichtbar, und nach dem, was wir bisher
sehen, könnte dies ein wirklich
leistungsstarkes neues Modell sein.
Apropos Google: Berichten zufolge
bereiten sie auch ein neues
Nano-Banana-Modell vor, möglicherweise
das Nano-Banana 2.5, und die ersten
Ergebnisse sehen ziemlich beeindruckend
aus. Kommen wir zu DeepSeek: Wie ich
bereits in meinem ausführlichen
Testvideo erwähnt habe, wurde
offiziell DeepSeek Version 4.1 Flash
veröffentlicht. Es ist intelligenter,
schneller und effizienter und könnte
eines der besten Open-Source-Modelle
sein, die derzeit verfügbar sind. Wenn
man sich die Benchmarks ansieht, ist
die Leistung wirklich enorm. Es ist
wahnsinnig schnell, und einige der
Ergebnisse, die ich bisher getestet
habe, sind absolut beeindruckend.
Gestern haben wir auch darüber
gesprochen, dass OpenAI und Anthropic
angeblich an einem noch
leistungsfähigeren Modell arbeiten.
Wir haben sogar einen kleinen Einblick
in das bekommen, was möglicherweise
das OpenAI GPT-7-Modell sein könnte,
das eventuell mit dem Bell-Checkpoint
in Verbindung steht, über den wir
bereits berichtet haben und der
angeblich ein jahrzehntealtes
mathematisches Problem in nur wenigen
Tagen gelöst hat. Aber jetzt kommen
sogar noch verrücktere Informationen
ans Licht. Ich höre, dass OpenAI der
Verifizierung der Hodge-Vermutung
extrem nahekommen könnte. Nun,
entweder OpenAI oder Anthropic könnten
auch bei einem anderen Problem
ernsthafte Fortschritte machen. Beides
sind Probleme der Millennium-Preise.
Das basiert natürlich noch auf
Berichten und Gerüchten, also sollte
man es mit Vorsicht genießen, aber es
ist irgendwie wahnsinnig, denn dies
sind Millennium-Probleme, die seit
vielen Jahren ungelöst waren, nun aber
tatsächlich innerhalb weniger Monate
oder sogar Tage gelöst werden. Das ist
absolut verrückt, und es gibt noch so
viel mehr zu besprechen, also tauchen
wir einfach direkt ein. Dein
Coding-Agent hat 900 Zeilen geschrieben
, während du zu Mittag gegessen hast.
Sei ehrlich, hast du sie alle gelesen?
Niemand tut das. Wir überfliegen sie,
wir geben sie frei und wir hoffen das
Beste. Das Problem ist nicht der Code,
sondern dass die einzige Möglichkeit
für deinen Agenten, sich zu erklären,
eine weitere Textwüste ist. Scrimbas
neues „Explain“-Feature bietet eine
zweite Option. Du stellst eine Frage
und erhältst innerhalb von 2 oder 3
Sekunden ein Video als Antwort.
Verknüpfen Sie es mit Cloud Code for
Sir oder Codex mit deren MCP-Plugin und
es liest Ihr tatsächliches Repository.
Verweisen Sie auf einen Pull Request
und Ihr gesamtes Team sieht sich
endlich die Erklärung an, nicht nur
den Code. Leute fragen es alles
Mögliche, vom Lösen von Problemen bis
zur Messung des Brennstoffs der Sonne.
Sie können es auf der Website, in
ChatGPT oder direkt über die
Chrome-Erweiterung nutzen. Ein großes
Dankeschön an Scrimba für das
Sponsoring des heutigen Videos. Ich
empfehle Ihnen daher sehr, es
auszuprobieren–die Links finden Sie
unten in der Beschreibung. Scrimba
Explain, fragen Sie es einfach etwas.
Beginnen wir mit der GPT-6 Soul, die
offiziell in freier Wildbahn gesichtet
wurde. Vor wenigen Tagen gab es
Gerüchte, dass GPT-6 Soul bei OpenAI
intern getestet wird. Und nun sehen wir
erste Anzeichen dafür, dass das Modell
öffentlich auftaucht. Nach den ersten
vorliegenden Informationen scheint GPT-
6 Soul extrem schnell zu sein und zudem
eine deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber
GPT-5.6 Soul darzustellen. Wir wissen
noch nicht, wie groß dieser Sprung
sein wird, aber die Tatsache, dass es
bereits gesichtet wurde, bedeutet, dass
OpenAI kurz vor der Veröffentlichung
steht. Vielleicht sehen wir es sogar
noch vor dem DevDay, der später im
September stattfindet. Dies lässt mich
vermuten, dass OpenAI das GPT-6-
Rate-Limit-Problem schnell löst, indem
eine neue, abgestufte Version
veröffentlicht wird, die–natürlich
–etwas schwächer als Astra ist, aber
knapp darunter liegt, um die Rate
Limits nicht vollständig
auszuschöpfen. Als Nächstes: Google
hat heute einen brandneuen Gemini
Pro-Checkpoint veröffentlicht, der
merklich besser aussieht als der
vorherige. Ich muss sagen, dieser hier
wirkt in Bezug auf seine Leistung
ziemlich seriös. Einer der neuesten
Tests zeigte, wie Gemini Pro diesen
unglaublich detaillierten Pfau in SVG
erzeugte, komplett im
Zero-Shot-Verfahren. Es verbrauchte
etwa 24.000 Token, dauerte bei hohem
Reasoning-Aufwand etwa 6 Minuten und
das Endergebnis ist definitiv
beeindruckend. Auf jeden Fall besser
als einige Ergebnisse, die ich sogar
von Astra und Fable gesehen habe. Und
genau diese Modell-ID ist jetzt
öffentlich sichtbar. Wir wissen auch,
dass der vorherige Projekt-Checkpoint
Argon 160 hieß, was interessant ist,
und er wurde in der Arena unter dem
Namen Gemini 3.8 Flash getestet. Google
arbeitet also eindeutig hinter den
Kulissen an diesen Projekt-Checkpoints
weiter, und ich gehe davon aus, dass
dies geschieht, um zu trainieren und
alles für die Gemini Pro 4.0-Serie
vorzubereiten. Es gibt viele
Entwicklungen im Bereich KI, die ich
nicht direkt auf meinem YouTube-Kanal
präsentiere, auf die ihr aber über
meinen kostenlosen Newsletter zugreifen
könnt. Der Link dazu steht in der
Videobeschreibung, und ihr könnt ihn
dort völlig gratis abonnieren. Als
Nächstes: Wie ich euch in meinem
letzten Video erzählt habe, in dem ich
DeepSeek Version 4.1 Flash vorab
getestet habe, wurde das Modell heute
offiziell veröffentlicht. Dieses
DeepSeek 4.1 Flash-Modell ist
intelligenter, schneller und
effizienter konzipiert und bietet zudem
native Vision-Fähigkeiten. Was jedoch
wirklich interessant ist, ist die neue
Architektur, die DeepSeek verwendet. Es
ist ein riesiges MoE-Modell mit 552
Milliarden Parametern, aber dank seiner
neuen
Causal-Encoder-Decoder-Architektur
aktiviert es nur etwa 8 Milliarden
Parameter für die Eingabe und 16
Milliarden für die Ausgabe–was
eigentlich kaum zu glauben ist. Im
Grunde versucht DeepSeek, mehr
Intelligenz bei deutlich geringerem
Rechenaufwand zu liefern. Sie haben
zudem neue Vortrainingsmethoden sowie
ein umfangreicheres Reinforcement
Learning eingeführt. Laut DeepSeek
übertreffen die Ergebnisse der Version
4.1 Flash in vielen verschiedenen
Benchmarks einige der
Flaggschiff-Modelle, natürlich
einschließlich der Version 4 Pro, und
zwar in fast jedem Test. Wenn man sich
die Benchmarks tatsächlich ansieht,
zeigt dies deutlich, wie nah es an
diese Flaggschiff-Modelle heranreicht.
Auf der „World of AI“-Benchmark-und
Viper-Coding-Plattform haben wir dieses
Modell rigoros getestet, und dabei sind
wir zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass es in
der Gesamtwertung über alle unsere
Benchmarks hinweg den siebten Platz
belegt. Es überzeugt in fast allen
Bereichen, und die Tatsache, dass es in
der Lage ist, Kimi K3 zu übertreffen,
ist schon verrückt. Leute, das hier
ist eine Flash-Variante. DeepSeek hat
mit diesem Modell wirklich ganze Arbeit
geleistet; es ist ein Modell, das in
vielen generativen Workflows glänzt.
Ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, es sich
anzusehen und auszuprobieren, um zu
sehen, wie ihr es in euren eigenen
Benchmarks nutzen könnt und um ein
besseres Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
was damit möglich ist. Dies gewährt
euch zudem kostenlosen Zugriff auf
meine Prompt-Bibliothek, daher empfehle
ich euch sehr, auch das einmal
auszuprobieren. Hier ist nun ein
Vergleich zwischen DeepSeek Version 4.1
Flash und Gemini 3.8 Flash, bei dem
beide anhand verschiedener 3
D-Geometrie-Aufgaben gegenübergestellt
werden. Dabei wurden beiden Modellen
sechs verschiedene 3 D-Geometrietests
vorgelegt, die sie im
Zero-Shot-Verfahren lösen mussten,
darunter auch ein Torusknoten. Dazu
kommen ein Menger-Schwamm sowie ein
paar andere komplexe Szenen. Dies wurde
mithilfe von KI-und ML-APIs umgesetzt,
und was die Effizienz betrifft, war
Gemini der klare Sieger, da es weniger
Token verbraucht und zudem
kostengünstiger ist. Doch bei der
Überprüfung der Ergebnisqualität
übertraf DeepSeek Version 4.1 Flash in
vielen Ausgaben sogar Gemini 3.8 Flash,
was wirklich erfreulich ist. Über alle
sechs Ergebnisse hinweg kostete es mit
Gemini nur 11 Cent, während es bei
DeepSeek etwa 27 Cent kostete. Ich
betone das in meinem vollständigen
Demovideo, dessen Anschauung ich sehr
empfehle, aber hier wird DeepSeek
Version 4.1 Flash bei Betrachtung der
Preise erst richtig verrückt. Ich
weiß, in diesem Vergleich sahen wir,
dass das DeepSeek-Modell viel teurer
war bzw. das Gemini-Modell viel
günstiger als DeepSeek. Doch auf dem
Terminal Bench 2.1 erreichte die
Version 4.1 Flash angeblich 90,6 Punkte
und liegt damit vor vielen anderen
Modellen wie Opus 5, Gemini 1.5 Pro und
sogar DeepSeeks eigener Version 4 Pro.
Und wenn man dieses Modell mit diesen
Giganten vergleicht, ergibt die
Preisgestaltung absolut Sinn, denn
DeepSeek berechnet nur 30 Cent pro
Million Eingabe-Token und 1,20 Dollar
pro Million Ausgabe-Token. Man erhält
also auch in Nebenzeiten noch
günstigere Preise, was dies zu einer
deutlich preiswerteren Option im
Vergleich zu diesen
Flaggschiff-Modellen macht. Und denkt
daran, Leute: Dies ist ein Modell, das
unglaublich schnell ist. Man erreicht
etwa 300 bis 400 Token pro Sekunde, was
irgendwie irre ist. Das ist krass, denn
es hat einen vollständigen FPS-Shooter
erstellt. Das ist DeepSeek Version 4.1
Flash, Leute. Das ist nicht Astra, das
ist nicht Fable. Das wurde vollständig
vom DeepSeek-Modell programmiert. Es
gibt Animationen, Farbtöne und sogar
dynamische Bewegungen wie in echten
FPS-Shootern. Und das Modell konnte
sogar alle Texturen sowie funktionale
Komponenten wie verschiedene Waffen und
Spielstile hinzufügen–es ist
wirklich unglaublich, dass das
DeepSeek-Modell dazu fähig ist. Ich
hatte anfangs keine großen Erwartungen
an DeepSeek, aber es sieht so aus, als
würden sie ein wirklich starkes
Comeback feiern. In Zukunft könnte es
auch im Bereich KI und Mathematik
absolut verrückt werden, ebenso wie
bei diesem neuen Modell, das derzeit
von OpenAI trainiert wird, dem
GPT-Bell-Modell. Dieser Checkpoint wird
wahrscheinlich GPT 6.5 oder sogar GPT 7
sein. Anthropic hat zudem ein geheimes
Modell, das weit überlegen gegenüber
Fable ist. Beide Labore verfügen über
dieses unglaubliche neue KI-System, das
sie beide trainieren, und beide lösen
damit einige unglaubliche Probleme, die
seit vielen Jahren ungelöst sind.
Einigen neuen Gerüchten zufolge kommt
OpenAI dem Beweis der Hodge-Vermutung
sehr nahe, was etwas ist, das seit
vielen, vielen Jahren ungelöst
geblieben ist. Und sie machen auch
ernsthafte Fortschritte bei der Lösung
der Birch-Vermutung. Dies sind zwei
berühmte Millennium-Probleme, einige
der schwierigsten ungelösten Probleme
der Mathematik. Und anscheinend ist das
Rennen, das hinter den Kulissen
zwischen diesen Laboren stattfindet,
mit nichts zu vergleichen, was wir
jemals zuvor gesehen haben. Wenn diese
Berichte tatsächlich wahr sind, was
höchstwahrscheinlich der Fall ist, da
OpenAI einen der Berichte bestätigt
hat, könnten wir möglicherweise
erleben, wie drei Millennium-Probleme
innerhalb eines einzigen Monats gelöst
werden, was absolut historisch wäre.
Natürlich sind das noch unbestätigte
Gerüchte, also nehmt es mit Vorsicht,
aber das ist irgendwie verrückt, Leute
. Wir erreichen einen Punkt, an dem die
KI wahnsinnig schnell voranschreitet.
Wenn euch dieses Video gefällt und ihr
den Kanal unterstützen möchtet,
könnt ihr eine Spende über die Super
Thanks-Option unter dem Video in
Betracht ziehen. Oder ihr könnt
unserem privaten Discord beitreten, wo
ihr monatlich kostenlosen Zugang zu
mehreren Abonnements verschiedener
KI-Tools sowie tägliche KI-News,
exklusive Inhalte und vieles mehr
erhaltet.
Kommen wir zu Google: Ein mysteriöses
neues Nano-Banana-Bildmodell namens
Spicy Mayo–lustiger Name–ist in
Eleonora aufgetaucht, und es ist noch
unklar, was genau das ist. Es ist
vielleicht nicht das Nano Banana 2.5,
könnte aber ein Flash-oder
Light-Update sein. Wir haben bereits
das GPT-Bildmodell 2.5, das gerade von
OpenAI veröffentlicht wurde. Es ergibt
also Sinn, dass Google versucht, mit
dieser neuen Variante Marktanteile zu
gewinnen, und die Veröffentlichung
könnte sehr bald erfolgen. Es gibt
tatsächlich einen Vergleich zwischen
dem GPT-Bildmodell 2.5 und dem
Spicy-Mayo-Checkpoint, bei dem der
gleiche Minecraft-Kamel-Prompt
verwendet wurde, bei dem man die
Benutzeroberfläche des Sandbox-Spiels
nachbilden möchte. Das GPT-Bildmodell
2.5 produzierte dabei die genauere
Spieloberfläche, während Spicy Mayo
ein optisch ansprechenderes Bild
erzeugte. Es ist wirklich eine Frage
der persönlichen Vorliebe, welches
Modell bei der Generierung dieses
Bildes bessere Arbeit geleistet hat,
aber in Bezug auf die Genauigkeit hat
GPT die bessere Arbeit geleistet. Was
jedoch ein optisch ansprechenderes Bild
angeht, denke ich, dass das
Gemini-Modell das GPT-Modell
übertroffen hat. Ein wirklich kleines
Update, aber ChatGPT Voice kann jetzt
GPT 5.6 Soul und GPT 6 Astra verwenden.
Natürlich macht dies die
Sprachintelligenz weitaus klüger, da
sie diese neueren Modelle nutzt, die
offensichtlich einen späteren
Wissensstand haben. Und natürlich
verfügen die Modelle selbst über mehr
Intelligenz. OpenAI hört nicht auf,
Neues zu veröffentlichen, denn sie
haben gerade einen neuen Daten-Agenten
für ChatGPT Work eingeführt, mit dem
man bestehende Datenquellen des
Unternehmens verbinden und einfach
Fragen stellen kann, um Daten in
Antworten, interaktive Dashboards und
sogar Aktionen zu verwandeln. Man kann
sogar das Daten-Plugin hinzufügen,
seine Quellen verbinden und direkt mit
den Daten des eigenen Unternehmens
chatten. Aber das war es auch schon,
Leute, für das heutige Video zu den
aktuellen Entwicklungen in der Welt der
KI. Falls ihr unseren World of AI
Insider Club noch nicht kennt–unsere
School-Community, in der ihr Zugang zu
vielen coolen Vorteilen wie kostenlosen
monatlichen KI-Abonnements, Vorabzugang
zu KI-Modellen und vielem mehr erhaltet
–, kann ich euch nur empfehlen, einen
Blick auf die Links in der
Videobeschreibung zu werfen. Außerdem
erhaltet ihr kostenlosen Zugang zur
World of AI Bot Camp-Plattform und zum
Benchmark. Auch das solltet ihr euch
über die Links in der Beschreibung
ansehen. Schaut auf unserem zweiten
Kanal vorbei, abonniert den Newsletter,
tretet dem Discord bei, folgt mir auf
Twitter und stellt zu guter Letzt
sicher, dass ihr den Kanal abonniert,
die Glocke aktiviert, das Video likt
und euch unsere vorherigen Videos
anseht, damit ihr über die neuesten
KI-Nachrichten und Entwicklungen in
diesem Bereich auf dem Laufenden bleibt
. In diesem Sinne, Leute, habt einen
großartigen Tag, verbreitet
Positivität und wir sehen uns ganz
bald wieder. Macht's gut, Leute.